Par son histoire et de par son projet politique actuel,
le Rassemblement National n'a pas sa place
à la panthéonisation de missac Émilie némanouchiante.
Parce que son histoire,
il y a eu des créateurs qui,
dans parmi les créateurs du Front National,
il y en a qui ont pourchassé les F T P M O I,
dont misac émileiné manouchan et dont, euh,
ceux qui ont tenu les fusils à l'encontre de misac, euh
de de misac manouchan.
Et 2e sujet par rapport à son projet politique actuel,
parce que la panthéonisation de misac, euh,
émileiné manouchan,
c'est aussi la vision qu'on a de la nation française
et ce n'est pas 1 vision etnissiste
de la nation française,
contrairement au
projet qui est actuellement
porté par le Rassemblement National.
Lorsqu'on remet en cause le droit du sol,
et bien pour vous,
vous n'aurez jamais accepté
que missac Émilien et manouchan soient des français
et c'est ça la réalité,
et c'est pour cela que vous n'avez pas votre place.
Et la venue de Marine Le Pen, euh,
à cette pantéonisation
est 1 crachat à la figure des résistants
de la France, et je vous le dis,
vous pouvez rire monsieur,
mais non, parce que y a 1 peu de décence,
et je veux dire, il y a eu 1 peu de décence, il y a eu,
euh, la juriste prudence quand-même, bas d'Inter, ou
euh, la famille de bas d'Inter,
notamment son épouse, a demandé à,
est-ce que vous ne veniez pas ?
Et bien aujourd'hui. On a les enfants, les petits-enfants,
la famille de missac,
Émilie némanouchiante et 23 STP
qui demande à ce que Marine Le Pen ne vienne pas
et bien la descente aurait été de s'abstenir
et de ne pas venir
et surtout je tiens le souligner,
de ne pas faire 1 polémique
et de ne pas faire le procès du parti comiste français
alors où il fait son entrée au panthé.